from the air and underground hundreds of
firefighters and soldiers from the
Colombian Army have been battling Around
the Clock against dozens of forest fires
burning across the
country in the capital bot there are at
least six fires in the city's
surrounding Hills some of them close to
buildings and
houses emergency teams are using hose
rakes and machetes to create fire brakes
on the sloping Hills to contain the
fires some hotpots are still active they
are being contained but at night because
of the high altitude in the winds they
flare up again creating new
fires on the streets of bota many are
wearing masks to deal with a worsening
air quality schools and universities
close to the fire were closed and dozens
of flights canceled or delayed due to
low visibility it's the worst I have
seen in many years and I have been
leaving three blocks from here for 45
years experts say a particular
particularly severe dry season
compounded by El Nino weather phenomenon
which typically produces hotter and
drier weather together with climate
change are to blame but they're not
excluding a human hand in some of the
outbreaks overall Colombia's put out
more than 200 fires this month across
much of the country around 8 per day as
cities and towns face record
temperatures the government says it has
already spent almost half of the budget
say out for confronting El noo president
Gustavo Petro declared a natural
disaster to transfer more resources to
fight the fires and pleaded for
International Help the fundamental
problem during this season is not just a
lack of water but the heat as well the
water evaporates and the fire happens
it's an aggravated El Nino phenomenon
and on top of that you have global
warming the climate crisis meterologists
fear that this could be just the
beginning of an extended and possibly
unprecedented dry spell that could bring
more fires and droughts across much of
the country and many also fear that
Colombia might be ill prepared for it
Alexander retti Al jaaz
bot make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer